6 15 here on a tuesday morning it's been
almost five years since the one october
shooting on the south end of the las
vegas strip and plans are moving forward
now to honor the lives lost the
thousands of survivors that were there
and the first responders who stepped up
in the time of need the one october
committees we've been talking about is
looking for ideas on a memorial that
will be placed at the site of the
shooting near mandalay bay and joining
us this morning to talk about that
everett it's been going on for a while
here daniel pereira from the one october
committee you're the chair of the
memorial committee it's good to see you
thank you good morning good to see you
again so uh let's just
first of all talk about where clark
county is in the process the committee's
been around for a while now trying to
work through and and do it methodically
but do it the right way absolutely so
we've been
very mindful
of the importance of this memorial
because it really truly is important for
so many
important for healing and so we've
methodically worked through to develop a
process
where the community can be involved in
this and so we're at the stage right now
where we're looking for creative ideas
and expressions from the community so
they can share their story looking at
scenes of course this is where the the
tragedy took place you mentioned people
can take part and submit their own ideas
there's the gallery online uh heather
and i were clicking on it a little bit
this morning
what can people do if they want to
contribute their own
feelings their emotions their artwork
whatever what do they have to do to take
part so they can go on our website
clarkcountynv.gov one october memorial
there's an app it's a very simple
process and just upload their creative
expression that can be you know a range
of things we're just asking people to
share
those ideas and those expressions
because this is their direct link to the
design teams so help inspire those
design teams with their stories so we
end up with a collective memorial and
you know if you're trying to get so much
response from the community about one
october and their experiences that lends
itself to the idea this is going to be a
big project and it has been a big
project what kind of size and scale
is the committee thinking about uh for
the memorial
so we've really left it up to the
community on what they want to see and
what this will be but we do know that we
have two acres so mgm did donate two
acres from the venue so the site of the
tragedy so
you know it could really range we've
heard from the community they would like
indoor outdoor type of space and there's
some other things that came out of the
focus groups and surveys that we did
but this is a community memorial final
quick question here
there's the healing guard in downtown
it's been there since the shooting
happened
why is this memorial needed for clark
county for las vegas for for people who
were there so the hilling garden is this
beautiful organic
kind of intermediate memorial that
cropped up
the one that we're working on now is the
permanent memorial and so this is
intended to really go back and capture
everything so the hilling garden kind of
is existed through the healing phase
the permanent memorial will really
capture all of that yes so something
long-term that to remember the victims
and honor the survivors daniel pereira
good to see you again from the one
october committee soon we'll follow the
process as it goes along